- [Voiceover] What fraction
of the circle is shaded red?
So let's see, this circle is divided into
one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight equal parts,
and of those eight equal
parts seven are shaded red.
So, we can say that seven
out of eight are shaded red,
and this isn't how we
traditionally seen fraction
when we've written them.
When we've written them
we've written it like this.
We have written seven
over eight are shaded red.
And actually, let me do it in that color,
oh, I don't have that exact,
let me get closer to an actual red color.
So, we could literally say seven out of,
and then we need like a grey color was,
was the non-shaded.
Seven out of a total eight are shaded red.
Are shaded red, that's how
we're used to seeing it,
but sometimes, or usually
when we type it in
there's no way to write
the seven over the eight,
so instead, instead we
write seven over eight.
Over eight are shaded red,
or seven out of eight.
So, let's do that.
Go back to what we we're doing.
So, seven out of eight are shaded red.
Let's check our answer.
Let's do two more of these.
What fraction of the bar is shaded red?
So, the bar has one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
nine equal sections,
and eight of them are shaded red.
So, we can say that eight
out of nine are shaded red,
or eight-ninths, or eight over nine.
Let's do one more.
What fraction of this
circle is shaded red?
So, we have one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
nine equal sections.
Did I count that right?
Let me count again.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine equal sections,
and of those one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven are shaded red.
So, seven out of nine, or
seven-ninths are shaded red.